(soft acoustic music)
- I'm just gonna tell you
a little bit about my mom.
- I am going to tell you about my mom.
- I was raised by my mom and my abuelita.
So I like to say I was raised
in a space of matriarchal magic.
- My dad, he just, he wasn't around,
so my mom really had to you
know, pick up the slack.
- It was just the two of us,
up until I left for college.
And that was our family unit.
- My mom was left with four kids,
a 15-year-old, a 14-year-old,
an eight-year-old, and a three-year-old.
- I was raised by two very powerful,
very tireless women, tireless mothers,
for that matter, both
of whom, have not only
taught me about patience, but about
the myriad of ways in
which family can manifest.
- My mom was mom and dad for
me for so much of my life.
And I'm just really grateful for it.
- She didn't have a degree.
She didn't have a job of any
kind when she moved out there.
She would just, was
forced to figure it out.
- She was able to get us out
of a very unhealthy marriage.
She did it all on her own.
- It's just now, as an adult,
I'm starting to realize
how strong my mom is.
- She would work, but
she also went to school
on the weekend, too, and then,
she worked full time during the week.
- She works six days out of the week,
just to provide for me and my sister.
She never complains.
She has the best sense of humor.
- She started a house cleaning business,
that since its conception, has allowed her
to provide me with
everything that I've needed
to have a good start to my life.
- Growing up, I never knew
that anything was wrong.
I always had everything I wanted,
any toy, any game system, all of it,
my mom just got me stuff.
I mean, my mom was the Easter Bunny,
the Tooth Fairy, Santa, everything.
We never wanted for anything in the world.
And then, the older I got, the more
I realized she sacrificed so much.
- She was there every
single sporting outing,
every single choir concert.
No matter how far it was, she was there,
and she was cheering me on.
- My mom took it upon herself
to teach me how to drive.
And she said, "Mija, if you want to drive,
"you gotta learn how to change a tire,
"how to check oil, how
to do all that stuff."
And I said, "Mom," (clicks
her tongue) I was like,
"What are you gonna teach
me about doing that?
"You're a girl."
And she's like, "Sweetie,
you got it all wrong."
This lady walked out the house,
popped the hood to her truck,
and this lady just starts going at it.
- After my dad passed, my mom would
put us all to bed, and go to her room,
and cry herself to sleep.
- When I was growing up, I
didn't always appreciate,
let alone, fully
comprehend the real impact
of the burden that she had to carry
as primary provider of our household.
- Shout out to all the single moms who are
pushing forward, and just doing everything
they can to provide for their kids.
I really, really wish I had understood
how much my mom was
doing at a younger age,
so I could have helped
her a little bit more.
- She is the biggest believer in me,
in this entire world, more so than myself.
She doesn't ever fail to
tell me that she loves me.
- She was always proud of me.
Very proud, I don't know why.
She was always proud of
me, didn't matter for what.
- I don't know.
I don't think single
moms get enough credit,
because it takes a lot
to be both mom and dad.
You really do give up a lot of yourself
when you're raising people.
- Mom, Abuelita, I am so gratefully
indebted to the both of you.
Thank you for all of the love and support.
- I guess all that remains
to be said is thank you, Mom.
I love you a lot.
- Gracias, Mama.
Te amo.